[Music]
when it comes to
losing weight and getting feed we always
highlight the importance of
exercising and eating a well-balanced
diet there are millions of workout
videos and meal prep
videos out there yes it is important to
move daily and eat well
and that's something i always place
emphasis on as well however
one of the most important aspects that
people tend to neglect and something
we don't often talk about is sleep
when i mentioned about getting enough
rest i'm sure the first thing that comes
to your mind
is yup i've heard this too
many times get at least seven to eight
hours of sleep a night
but have you asked yourself why what is
the reason
why is it so important what happens when
you
sleep what does lack of sleep do to your
body if you think about it
we spend one third of our lives sleeping
so if you're 30 years old you have been
sleeping for 10
years so ask yourself how important is
sleeping to your overall well-being
often times lacking sleep is the reason
that's stopping you
from losing weight and seeing results
most of us have a consistent training
routine and we consume a well-balanced
diet however you still fail to see
results in your fitness journey
if you fix your sleeping habits i can
assure you
you will lose weight get fitter see
results quicker
and feel a lot healthier overall for
many of us
who have been lacking sleep we've
forgotten what being
really truly rested feels like we are
woken up
every day by the sound of our alarm
clock and we drag ourselves
out of bed for some of you it's a never
ending cycle for many years
and remember this you can't make up or
replace
the lack of sleep by sleeping longer
hours later
on our body doesn't function that way
i wish i could spend many late nights
and push through
all the date lines and once everything
is done i'll
catch up with my sleep and spend the
next one week sleeping
it just doesn't work that way
to get the most out of our sleep both
quantity and quality
are important while you're sleeping each
night your body typically goes through
several sleep cycles
in each cycle you alternate between two
types of sleep
non-rapid eye movement and rapid eye
movement
to keep it simple as we begin to fall
asleep we enter the
nrem cycle this includes the stages of
light sleep and deep sleep
what you really want is to have a longer
deep
sleep in order to get a good quality
sleep
on the other hand the rem stage is
associated with vivid dreams
if your sleep is cut short the body
doesn't have time to complete
all the phases needed for muscle repair
memory consolidation
and release of hormones regulating
growth and appetite
that's when weight gain can happen and
this will also hinder your weight loss
goal
here are 5 things that will happen when
you lack
sleep
here's a very common misconception many
people think that
hunger and controlling your craving is
related to willpower
if i fail to control my cravings that's
because i
lack in willpower and i've failed well
that's actually incorrect
your hunger is controlled by two
hormones
latin and ghrelin latin is a hormone
that is produced in your fat cells
it is the hormone that decreases
appetite
when leptin levels are high we usually
feel
fuller on the other hand ghrelin is a
hormone that can stimulate
appetite aka the hunger hormone
the more ghrelin your body produce the
more you stimulate hunger
simply put losing weight comes down to
controlling these two hormones
leptin and ghrelin when you're sleeping
less than
6 hours a day this decreases leptin and
increases ghrelin
which stimulates your appetite making
you crave for more
high sugar and high fat foods if
i lack sleep i want all my sugary treats
and i'm never satisfied no matter how
much i eat
at the same time you're also putting
your body under stress
which increases the cortisol levels in
your body
cortisol is a stress hormone that
enlarges fat
cells and promotes fat storage in the
belly
so if you have come across people who
are skinny but with more fat
accumulation around their belly
it can be due to their stress levels a
combination of high levels of ghrelin
and cortisol in your body is a disaster
it will shut down the areas in your
brain that leave you feeling satisfied
after a meal
hence if you like sleep you will find
yourself constantly hungry and crave for
junk food
even if you just ate a big meal that's
not due to
lack of willpower but a havoc on the
hormones in your body
when you have no control over what you
eat and never feeling satisfied
that's when you will reach for bigger
portions and consume unhealthy
calorie dense food which will increase
your total calorie intake
a study has shown that people who slept
less than 5 hours
consume an average of 550
more calories the following day when you
are spending more time awake especially
late in the night
chances are you'll be mindlessly
munching away to keep yourself awake
those are all additional calories which
you won't be consuming
if you're sleeping at the right hours so
little by little
it will add on and this will lead to
weight gain over time
i've mentioned this many times in my
previous videos weight loss and weight
gain comes down to
one simple principle of energy balance
to lose weight you have to create a
negative energy balance
that means your total daily energy
expenditure
should be more than what you consume
however if you're eating more than what
your body is able to burn
that's when weight gain happens
sleep also influences your metabolism
especially glucose metabolism
when we eat our bodies release insulin a
hormone that helps to process the
glucose in our blood
lack of sleep can affect our body's
response to insulin
your body's insulin sensitivity can drop
by more than 30
and here's why that is bad
when your insulin is functioning well
fat cells remove
fatty acids and lipids from your
bloodstream and prevent storage
when you become more insulin resistant
fats
circulate in your blood and pump out
more insulin
an excess of glucose ends up being
converted to fatty acids
and being stored as fat in all the wrong
places
such as around your belly so in the long
term
this will lead to weight gain and even
health conditions like type 2 diabetes
we've spoken about how sleep affects
your food intake
unfortunately lack of sleep also have an
impact on your workouts
we want to increase lean muscle mass and
reduce body fat
having more lean muscle mass increases
your metabolism
helping you to burn fat more efficiently
this will also help you to maintain a
healthy body weight
long term however lack of sleep is
the enemy of our muscle sleep
deprivation can decrease
protein synthesis which is your body's
ability to increase
muscle it can also cause muscle loss and
lead to higher risk of injuries
i'm sure you have experienced this
yourself when you're tired and exhausted
you don't feel like working out even if
you do your training might not be at 100
everything you do feels much more
challenging and you struggle to give
your best effort lack of sleep will also
make it harder for your body to recover
that's because the production of growth
hormones that helps with fat burning and
also recovery
slows down in your body so when your
body can't
recover you can't progress in your
workout
most times people think that by spending
more hours exercising
it will speed up their results that's
absolutely
not true results come from getting
adequate time
in recovery because your muscle grows
and repairs when you rest
not when you work out so if you find
yourself hitting a plateau or not seeing
results
even though you're putting lots of
effort in your training
it can be due to your sleeping habits
and not prioritizing
your recovery
so now that you know the importance of
sleep and how it can help with weight
loss
here are some simple tips for you to
increase the quality of your sleep
[Music]
just like having a routine to eat and
exercise you need to establish a regular
sleep routine as well
this will maintain the timing of the
body's internal clock and helps you
fall asleep and wake up more easily for
those of you who never have a sleep
routine before
it can be challenging to force yourself
to go to bed at a certain time
however it's just a matter of practicing
the routine
identifying what works and what doesn't
work and make adjustments
until you fall into a consistent routine
[Music]
don't eat a heavy meal right before bed
if you find yourself craving a late
night snack
avoid eating a large meal eating a heavy
meal before
bed can cause the body's metabolism to
slow
and it can make it harder for you to
fall asleep if you are craving at night
chances are it's late and you just need
to go to bed and sleep if however you
are really hungry
then have a small snack such as a piece
of toast
fruits or oatmeal something healthy just
to keep you satisfied
[Music]
hands up if the last thing you look at
before going to bed
is your phone let's be honest i'm guilty
of that myself
what's the function of your mobile phone
it's to keep you connected and alert
correct
so if you're mindlessly scrolling
through your social media feed
watching videos even if you're already
feeling sleepy this can trick
your brain into thinking that it needs
to stay awake
what's worse is when you struggle to
disconnect yourself
from your work emails or text messages
the blue
light from our smartphones and other
electronic devices
has been shown to reduce or delay the
natural production of melatonin
and decrease the feelings of sleepiness
melatonin is a hormone responsible for
controlling
your sleep wake cycle so when your body
runs
low on it you can experience insomnia
tightness during the day and
irritability nowadays there are many
options on your phone to set the night
time mode where you can keep the
notifications switched off and minimize
distractions
at least 30 minutes before your bedtime
you don't always have to
be connected on your phone instead spend
the time to
really connect with your loved ones
before bedtime
sleep is one of the most important
aspects of our life
health and longevity yet it is
increasingly neglected in society
nowadays
due to work electronic devices and so on
when we sleep we wake up feeling
refreshed and alert to start our day
sleep affects how we look
feel and perform on a daily basis and
can have a major impact on our
overall quality of life beyond just
eating well
and exercising regularly sleep is one of
the most important
aspects in losing weight and maintaining
a healthy weight for life
so what are your sleeping habits let me
know in the comments below
and what areas can you improve on if you
find this video to be useful
do give this video a thumbs up share it
on with your friends
and do also check out other fitness
videos on my youtube channel
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
and
get off your mobile phone and get some
sleep and i will see you next time
all the best